buenos días como comentabas de angela
reunión extraordinaria de los líderes
europeos aquí en bruselas muy enfocado
en las relaciones exteriores de la unión
europea por una parte los líderes
europeos tienen la difícil tarea de
aprobar sanciones contra bielorrusia
básicamente contra otros cargos del
régimen también está sobre la mesa qué
pasará si se aplicarán sanciones contra
alexander lukashenko algo que ya ha
hecho reino unido porque recordemos ya
no es un país porque forma parte de la
unión europea pero lo cierto es que la
unión europea sigue incapaz en casi dos
meses después de las elecciones en
bielorrusia en aplicar sanciones porque
como has comentado se requiere
unanimidad y está unanimidad no aún no
ha sido alcanzada básicamente porque
chipre bloquea porque insiste en que
quiere la misma mano dura con turquía
porque turquía también está hoy en la
agenda las complicadísimas relaciones
con este país socio estratégico de la
unión europea un socio muy incómodo pero
muy importante para la unión europea
turquía insiste en la extracción de gas
y petróleo en las aguas cercanas a
chipre algo que contraviene el derecho
internacional pero
la unión europe insiste en que la única
solución es el diálogo y de momento las
sanciones no están encima de la mesa
otra cuestión que va a planear el horno
a pensar que no está en la agenda es la
ratificación del fondo de recuperación
que se aprobó el pasado julio porque
hungría y polonia insisten en que los
fondos no deben estar ligados al estado
de derecho
esther y hablemos de break sido hoy se
conoció que la comisión europea ya
emprendió acción legal contra el reino
unido por su ley de mercado interno que
viola las reglas de la salida cuáles son
las consecuencias de las medidas por
parte de bruselas
lo cierto es que las medidas que son
sobre todo en unas consecuencias
básicamente políticas porque lo cierto
es que el proceso es bastante largo
hasta que llegue el caso al tribunal de
justicia de la unión europea pero es que
esta medida ha anunciado hoy por parte
de la comisión europea la verdad es que
intensa un poco más las negociaciones
actualmente hoy mismo aquí en bruselas
los dos equipos negociadores tanto el
europeo como el británico están
negociando un acuerdo comercial y lo
cierto es que hay varios puntos aún por
acabar de cerrar no hay muchas
esperanzas de que porsche puede acabar
de aquí a finales de mes poder aprobar
un acuerdo comercial algo que es básico
porque si no no habría tiempo para
ratificar este acuerdo pero la unión
europea ha querido cumplir así con unas
amenazas porque el reino unido ha
seguido adelante con su polémica ley
sobre el mercado interno que contraviene
los acuerdos del break sit y por lo
tanto la unión europea dice que quiere
seguir adelante aún así veremos si este
estira y afloja entre londres y bruselas
finalmente podrá conseguirse con un
acuerdo a finales
en eso